yeah Chinese cell phone maker Huawei has
launched a new device in Paris part of
its campaign to win over Western Europe
we always want to try and find a fashion
city and the Paris death delay the
passion passion city I think Europe is
always our key region and France at such
big city a big country as you need all
our key country this new handset will
compete with the latest iphone from
apple and galaxy from samsung the Ascend
p7 is slimmer than its rivals with an 8
megapixel front camera to keep those
selfies bright and colourful worldwide
Huawei sold nearly 14 million
smartphones during the first three
months of the year making the third
largest smartphone manufacturer with
China its biggest market us sales
meanwhile and non-existent after
officials accused the company of spying
against American interests but in Europe
huawei plans not only to sell handsets
but also to hire local talent from many
many years we sing a Europe should be
the center everybody in the war to
Europe so what we are the pioneer of the
hotel communication technology Huawei is
hoping customers in France and the rest
of Europe will soon start lining up and
then falling over themselves for these
new handsets phila marks for bloomberg